hello and welcome to this video this is
the second part of the reddit opening of
the week for week 3 2016 battling rare
first moose
yeah the first video was about one
before the orangutan or Sikorsky opening
and part two is about one b3 the
somewhat more restrained way of trying
to get the bishop to be to this is
usually called the Larsen opening or
nimzowitsch
Lars and opening yeah
black with many of those small moves
let's say it has a wide range of moves a
black and bass play basically anything
here and with some yeah with good good
hopes I had to equalize the game and
however I have to go four four one move
and my recommendation is quite clearly
1e5 if you can get that sent upon I
would just go for it
of course as I said you can go see five
d4 d5 other moves are also okay but a
filthy five is probably objectively with
a small margin the best move it is the
most active one at least
um yeah white here usually goes we
should be too checking the pawn and here
black I think should play knight c6
there are also number of people who play
d6 in this position the ideas to later
fianchetto and build up something that
is looking like a King's Indian of
course playable but I see no particular
reason to block my bishop and play 96 we
might as well get it developed later to
some active square or d6 we will see
some of that later yeah I'm here white
in most cases place the move III very
logical to develop
that bishop possibly played Bishop to b5
we should have a brief look at
alternatives on white player players
also have tried Knight f3 to attack that
pawn and yeah here black doesn't have a
great choice I mean okay you can play d6
but what's the point let's advance them
game time on that night Knight comes to
deform that is the usual continuation
and here black should simply take the
knight and play d5 very illogical play
grabbing the center and interesting in
the moment here is after e3 and while
black can play a number of moves here I
think that Bishop f5 is the strongest
one and even though you might never have
this on the board the idea is so
interesting to note what white would
like to get into is something like c4
yeah I'm just let's say black plays this
right and um
why play c4 and black plays c6 and white
eats and tanks and just is this is not
so bad yeah this Bishop is quite nicely
placed and white my turn yeah nipple at
the center here the e4 pawn and this can
also be slightly weak the d5 pawn after
the e-file II for porn gets traded this
is not a bad position at all
so what black would like to do is he
would like to play in the rain then
after c-4 and this is a mistake now he
has c5 Bishop goes back and now deform
and this is quite obviously good for
black hair with black we have a huge
advantage in space already and no
problems whatsoever so that's an
interesting idea simply to avoid an
early night f6 so that the bishop cannot
take if we play here I'm sorry if we
play here then something like this is
actually possible and 9c3 and now d5
looks we
10 their white gets control over that
square it's already a little bit awkward
for black so an interesting idea just to
keep in mind not just for this
particular position but I think it's
quite interesting to not play this early
on so we have C 5 and d4 available yeah
so black is basically delaying that a
little bit and for example if Y place I
some some some slow move we can and
circle here for example and wait
if white was c4 we go c5 black has
advantage in space here after 7 or so
that cannot be bad okay
that is a rare line or ever Knight f3
it's a rare line among or within the
pretty rare line in the first place and
one of the most famous games in the
Larson opening was with C form played
between yeah Larson and Boris Spassky in
1970
yeah Larson here experimented with the
move Knight f3 the normal move would be
e3 and this is something that we will
look at later by a different water 93 is
what Larson played and now it's
important to not play some lame move
they're not d6 or whatever
of course push the pawn forward a knight
comes to d4 and Bishop to c5 with tempo
yeah I mean white doesn't want to go
back so he took and like takes with the
D pawn of course III and Bishop and v
black is almost take on it's always
taking with the D pawn in this kind of
trade situation to get quickly developed
Bishop f5 Quincy to win yourself this is
the famous game which probably many of
you will know in this position on
Spassky already with black has a
slightly more comfortable position but
Larson's next moves yeah I really really
bad
mr. F 4 is already hmm very questionable
and 94 was a very strong reply by law by
a Spassky now white is struggling
already at this
III corneum can easily be the target of
a sacrifice there FY play sometimes a
move like that it's pretty nice
coming takes Bishop Jake's check check
and you know this is this is gone
the queen is now lost White has to go
here after which check this is going to
be the end of the game
yeah so that was a nice little line and
in the game after g3 age five age three
and now age four by Spassky here yeah he
won with the fantastic attack that's one
of the most famous games I believe rook
g1 es Bosque found very nice very nice
but not the only win but the very nice
win look to h1 for a temper with g2 and
yeah
Larsson resigned a couple of months
later after Ruchi one chat check and
create h1 black is quickly winning yeah
so this is a very nice game not the best
yeah
advertisement for the last and opening
his creator in a way or promote and
losing so quickly but it is not a bad
opening I mean we three is certainly
playable okay the main continuation
however here is the move III as I said
quite quite a logical move um here I
recommend to play Knight to f6 black
also made up for d5 very logical move
then drawback of it is that after
should be 5 Bishop d6 White has the move
f4 and this is not easy to handle I
tried to figure out if there is some
simple way for Black Joe to play this
but it doesn't seem to be that easy
there are some very sharp and somewhat
unconventional positions where I feel it
doesn't really pay off to look at it
because well you don't get it on the
board often and if you get b3 on the
board it can't be against some
specialist who is more knowledgeable
about those wacky positions that happen
here note that this is not possible as
Bishop g7 Queen h4 White has King f1 and
this is no attack whatsoever the rook is
the rook is lost simply there are some
lines that are similar where you can
take therefore an attack but here King
f1 is excellent for what yeah black in
fact has to play a six and we get very
strange positions where I think is it
night not quite sure I think what
sometimes even those Knight c3 year
something like that it was really weird
so I couldn't really recommend that for
for practical use let's say it's
something that you can of course explore
if you are let's say in a correspondence
game or if you have an offhand game that
is not so important but I feel for
competitive play d5 is a little bit
impractical to do someone my moves
Knight f6 just developed at night and
here is the mentioned possible
transposition to that loss and Spassky
game or that kind of set up with c4 here
white however has not played that now
they have three d4 thing yeah this move
c4 is not that popular Bishop e5 is by
far the main move but still c4 it's not
bad what white is basically doing is he
invites black to play
a Sicilian with colors reversed and this
is in fact what I do recommend I
understand that I mean because this one
I recommend to do that even if you are
not a 1/4 player or if you don't play
the open Sicilian I would still advise
to go for that I think that this is a
very comfortable version of an open
Sicilian with reversed colors and
relatively easy to play you don't need
any ya specific knowledge let's say like
when you battle against the night off
with wide where something very
theoretical might happen this is not the
case here so I think this is pretty a
pretty easy game for black I'll show a
little bit more there but I want to
point out that if you absolutely don't
like that idea to play some kind of open
Sicilian with reversed colors I still
recommend to do it but ok let's say you
absolutely don't want to then black has
alternatives here even though I think
they are theoretically less good than g
v g6 for example is something that you
can't play it it's never can never be a
bad move d5 I said as I said is a bit
more a bit more to the point it normally
did so something like that now they are
three d6 d4 and black might take 90 X
Bishop g7 this is of course perfectly
fine I mean why does some not having the
most aggressive setup here with with the
bishop on b2 and III and yeah I mean
this is about equal castles castles rook
e8 yeah if you play some kind of Kings
Indian if you have that in your
repertoire then this kind of position
probably you wouldn't mind to play
however if we go back d5 is my main
recommendation and by the way there is
not much else to be honest you can play
Bishop e7 let's say and castle but at
one point
you probably have to play d5 I mean it
doesn't make much sense not to so my
real movie is d5 cheeks stinks here um
black has this idea to go on the weak
square on d3 so white players and go 83
yeah that's the main move and here black
has a couple of options how to set up
his pieces and you can play with g6 for
example to bolster their pawn but I
think that the best continuation is
probably Bishop to d6 go for that set up
what we have to keep in mind is that
this is an open Sicilian or nice good
but white here has already committed to
a somewhat an aggressive setup it's with
the fianchetto that's not a given in the
Sicilian it happens often but it's where
the queenside fianchetto and it is with
b3 not with before where sometimes if we
think about the open Sicilian a b5b for
push might attack a void knight on c3
here white is already committed to some
kind of hedgehog yeah this is what
normally happens white players like
Quincy to castles d3 this is this kind
of thing and here a simple setup for
black is something with this like in
Queen to e7 possibly King h8 Bishop g4
if 9003 gets played and then some f5
it's very simple to play and it is not
as forcing and theoretically challenging
as a regular let's say open Sicilian so
I wouldn't mind to play that for example
even though I'm not only an e4 play and
have played like I don't know maybe 10
open Sicilians in my whole whole life
and in tournament shares with white so
why not yeah it's it's certainly a good
option um however if we go back why it's
main movie as
the move Bishop to b5 this is what you
will face in most of the games by far
and he formed quite a number of years
the main move is Bishop to d6 going to
show that briefly it's not what I'm
recommending but I mean it's good yeah
it's it's absolutely fine it's just that
I found that there is an another move
that I that I feel is quite interesting
and I want to shoot for that but should
be six is the main move it looks bit
strange to block that D pawn but okay if
five was attacked and blacks basic idea
is to Castle maybe rook e8 bring the
bishop back and then shoot 45 why not
now this is definitely playable it leads
to some interesting complications of an
after Knight to a3 with Knight C for
around the corner' where black is often
going for a six or 95 so it's a very
strange but seems to be an okay move
yeah this is a good alternative if you
for some reason don't like my move then
you can always go for Bishop d6 there's
nothing wrong with it it's just that I
saw that there's a second option and I
wasn't even aware that this existed
until I checked my database and I
thought this was it was very interesting
there is the movie form and to be honest
I think I've looked at this a couple of
months ago briefly and played it even in
a blitz game just a sing of it hmm
anyway I looked at this today and this
somewhat weird movie today is indeed
pretty strong yeah why is this strong I
mean it keeps that it keeps that pawn
safe it was attacked after all worth
taking and taking me five it gains space
it prevents Knight to f3 and it seems
just if you look at concrete moves then
why it doesn't have anything great that
you can do if d3 for example if you look
at a couple of
then black is just going a six and gets
the bishop pair and well this is just
excellent for black you know we have two
bishops for no I mean there is no kind
of compensation there for white and we
can be very happy this is at least
equality yes I think I mean I think most
people would prefer black yeah yeah I
guess um you can easily develop both
bishops can develop freedom let's say
ninety two for example and something
simple like Bishop f5 and white can
never really take on nav six as Queen f6
is a temple on the rook so something
like this this for example it's naughty
for of course not hanging as we attack
the rook in the corner yeah d3 doesn't
feel very threatening but yeah what does
in some games d4 has been tried
after which I think Black has a very
strong move that has not been played yet
but it's pretty logical Knight to e7
the idea is c6 and d5 building up a big
center and gaining time on the bishop
and it's pretty awkward there on b5 I
think white probably yeah wants to go
back now and get it out of the way so
that at least you can play some c4 the
computer has actually stockfish is
lacking bishop f1 giving black a slight
advantage of course already but bishop
f1 am now okay but should be too and
black just place this there's this it
has a position that yeah it's it's
typical white position that black has
more space and it looks like a pretty
good tiger for French defense um Bishop
a3 is an interesting move but black can
answer this easily was g6 and the
possible age 5 Bishop h6 and castles
like as it's sometimes seen in the
advanced French or the Kings Indian
attack that can
you're letting this bishop kind of yeah
look into into into the bank space um a
pretty good idea 97 defaults not very
challenging yeah what usually goes for
Knight to e2 we have like maybe a dozen
games also with that line it's not very
popular 92 and again black is happy to
just net the Bishop man this kind of
trade on c6 is very very common in this
opening however in most cases if we just
do a comparison comparison job in many
cases after the Bishop d6 for example
white place that capture in a situation
where he is able to play d3 and d4 this
is not a precise line now I know but I
just want to show you the basic idea
something something like this is what
happens quite often in this position
resembles some kind of exchange window
paths or delayed delayed exchange where
Lopez where why does putting this out
maybe night C 4 and so on note that the
pawn is only 5 in the line that that I'm
suggesting he 492 takes big stakes here
black has managed to push the pawn
forward so in this position we are not
in danger that this d3 d4 happens which
is not terrible for black but a pawn on
e5 is always limiting your bishop and
here with this before we have this
advantage in space and we can be sure
that both our bishops will be quite
active wide at some point we'll play d3
or f3 which we can just take and then he
has a center some center pawns but black
has very open development and the two
bishops in a recent game between granda
Zuniga the top Grandmaster from Peru and
the American young Grandmaster Daniel
narrowed its key this position was
reached and granda played 93
um if white castle's for example we have
a simple player planner of Bishop goes
to d6 and on a very good day we get to
sacrifice but probably this is not going
to happen
yeah so like this and this is a typical
way to play and yeah what we're probably
yeah play some kind of d3 f3 at some
point like a cz play rooky 8 we should
develop the bishop
everything looks simple and easy so 93
immediately is a little bit a little bit
more aggressive as white is not
committed to castling here this is a
mooster worth to remember it is not a
mandatory move but I think the the best
one h5 just play aggressively attack
this night with a quick edge 493 is
hanging and now Bishop g4 that was also
something prepared with h5 prepared by
h5 yeah now I have three takes takes and
now important move h4 yeah taking this
night that has to move and no I think
black has a good position he has at
least equalized
I would prefer black here a little bit
but it's not something terrible for
white either but black is definitely in
good shape in the game night f1 was
played if you go here which looks a
little bit more obvious than just Bishop
h5 mmm yeah black will Castle long and
it would be an interesting tense fight
but never forget black already has some
money in the bank with his two bishops
so in that if one was played in the
ground again and again Bishop to h5
Queen e2 Queen to d7 the three castles
castles in 95 now how this is how the
game went it ended in a draw ultimately
but I think this is a position that
black can be
happy with um b3 is not a bad opening at
all it is not as challenging as mainline
openings but it is definitely not
something questionable like 1g4 for
example which is as I mentioned already
in the video one about the Sikorsky is
really bad
b3 is something that can be easily
played I have played it myself a little
bit when I was a junior player to Pune
once in a while
avoid mainstream theory and it was
always fun to play something that is not
not as explored and if I believe if we
jump jump back it's a good principal
response it's not nothing that you
absolutely have to play you you are free
to play d5 c5 um and be okay as well but
I feel like e5 is very principled black
gets his fair share on the center and
has some chances to be better
also if white is playing in too much of
an extravagant way if we have seen for
example in that Lausanne Spassky game
this is not so easily possible if you
play something like b3 d5 or B 3 C 5
it's ok of course but it's not as
demanding from the white player that
same as one e5 you should definitely
play one in five if you are an e4 player
I believe just if you think about that
very comfortable open Sicilian with
reversed colors I think you can be very
happy with the positions okay well I
hope you enjoyed this collection of
simple recipes against one b3 and yeah
I'll continue with more videos against
the rare openings bye bye done with one
tomorrow thanks for watching